Speaker 1: We've got a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two. David P.
Here's a new caller. I have a feeling we
might be hearing from this guy frequently.
Speaker 5: Yeah, I listened to your show with a
joke, right? What a joke. You need to wake up.
Have you been to a store lately? Yes, shelves
are empty. Gas prices are doubled. Inflation is
at 30 one year. I mean, what a joke. You know, I
don't. I know you don't like Trump. Okay, that's
good. You don't like Lee tweets. Or you don't like
what he said about bleach. I mean, really grow up
being an adult. He had his foot on Putin's neck.
Speaker 1: OK, so there's a I think 11 is that I'd
have to go back. I think there were
11 lies there now. You know, I mean,
I've already spoken about gas prices and it's a
real problem. It's a problem in a number of ways.
It just doesn't really have to do with Joe Biden
Speaker 5: in North Korea under his thumb.
What a joke, really. You need to wake up
you and all your listeners in the wake
of you start passing that propaganda, that
democratic propaganda, you pass off as reality.
Speaker 1: I'm not even a Democrat.
Speaker 5: Yeah, we three things Trump won. Well,
or at least he would have won if there wasn't a
pandemic and you didn't, then those rules in your
favor so you could drop off ballots have carloads
of people pulling up, you know, and people mailing
in millions and millions of ballots.
Speaker 1: I think we're up to.
Is it eighteen lies so far? We're
only 51 seconds in, but eighteen lies
Speaker 5: that Trump would have
won if you didn't cheat. And that's
cheating. I don't know what you think. Cheating
is actually some grand conspiracy. The grand
conspiracy is Democrats changed the rules.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Remember, even Republican
legislatures also modified voting rules to
allow people to vote vote by mail who wouldn't
ordinarily be allowed to. It doesn't really
matter. But again, this is a reminder there's
people we can talk to reasonably, and there's
people we can't. That guy seems to be beyond
saving. We've got a great bonus show for you
today. We will actually talk about the Joe Biden
approval rating bump that happened. Is that
Ukraine? Is it the state of the Union? What
is it? We will talk about U.S. Olympic champion
Brittney Griner being arrested and held in Russia,
and we will talk about a man sentenced to prison
for using the COVID loan money that he got to buy
Pokemon cards, Pokemon cards, all of those stories
and more on today's bonus, Joe. I have some COVID
money fraud stories to tell myself not of anything
I did, but just if things have caught wind of.
Sign up at join Pacman Ocon, get instant
Unidentified: access to the bonus track.